salut bonjour comment est-ce que ça va
alors aujourd'hui on vous emmène dans un
endroit très cool ça s'appelle mwc à
barcelone et le mwcc quoique c'est le
gros salon international de la
téléphonie mobile et on commence tout de
suite on est lundi matin on est chez
opus avait créé ici une voix sur blanc
et si au fond il ya un truc très cool
qu'ils ont fait fin d'année dernière
s'appelle les inondations voire les
innovations et on entraperçoit le futur
et ce qui est vachement intéressant avec
au pot c'est qu'ils innovent énormément
pour apporter des techno qui arriveront
au final dans les smartphones peut-être
ou peut-être pas en tout cas les
innovations soient là donc je confie
tout de suite on pas perdre de temps on
va commencer par y aller directement
france bis on va regarder les
innovations d'ariane est ce qui va
arriver peut-être l'année prochaine
peut-être l'année d'après dans nos
smartphone ou peut-être jamais des
choses extrêmement intéressante on va
avoir un smartphone avec un zoom qui
apparaît réellement on a une caméra sous
l'écran également varades et quelle
manière le fait au pot qu'on naît de la
recharge extrêmement rapide pour
recharger son smartphone de 0 à 100 % en
seulement 15 minutes et puis on va se
projeter encore un peu plus loin dans le
futur avec la disparition probable du
smartphone la réalité augmentée de la
réalité mix enfin bref un sujet
extrêmement passionnant corps en garde
aujourd'hui ici sur le stand de haut
pour 1 mwc vous est prêt car il y va
c'est pas
[Musique]
alors ça je ne passerai rapidement nous
on s'en parle très bientôt sur youtube
enfin si vous regardez cette vidéo au
moment où elle va sortir et bien c'est
le finepix cinq pros la gamme finepix 5
qui arrive chez hop au sujet passionnant
mais ça c'est pour une prochaine fois
aujourd'hui on se projette sur des
choses un peu plus sera dématérialisée
mais pas sur des produits finis pour le
grand public donc on file juste derrière
et on va commencer par parler d'une
caméra qui très improbable en tout cas
du jamais vu alors la première chose est
super intéressante c'est sur ce
smartphone c'est un proto il n'existe
pas il a un truc qui est assez dingue
regardez voyez votre petit module caméra
là et bien lorsque j'appuie là vous avez
ici le module photo qui sort l'idée
c'est quoi c'est d'avoir un zoom optique
qui va aller plus loin mais réellement
optique c'est une optique variable
aujourd'hui lorsque vous prenez un
smartphone avec un téléobjectif vous
allez avoir notamment sur le finepix en
proa fois deux optiques mais c'est un
faux d'optique des convient ou mais
c'est du numérique et qu'est ce que ça
fait à terme et bien ça vient dégrader
un peu l'image là l'idée d'avoir
effectivement ce mouvement c'est à dire
votre caméra qui va bouger comme sur un
reflex en fait est bien c'est d'avoir un
zoom optique variable réellement
variable donc à terme pour imaginer les
landais sur un équivalent 52 mm pour
aller sur un 70 200 comme on aurait sur
un boîtier reflex peut-être peut-être
pas en tout cas tout je trouve assez
marrant alors c'est vraiment un proto on
se projette dans le futur on voit les
limites notamment les certifications il
paie ça va être compliqué devait
renaître une certification ip68 on a
connu effectivement sur les smartphones
et notamment les smartphones de au pot a
bien sauvé cette caméra qui bouge et pop
up avec l'aileron de requin il ya pas
mal de limites aujourd'hui qui sont
présentes pour venir certifier pour
venir garantir que vous n'ayez pas un
grain de sable ou de la poussière qu'ils
puissent rentrer dedans mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir où vont les
smartphones pour apporter des photos
toujours de meilleure qualité et le gros
travail qui est fait aussi ici au niveau
de l'idée du téléobjectif et ben ça me
plait énormément mais je sais pas vous
ce que vous en pensez dites le moi en
bas en commentaire moi perso je trouve
que l'idée hyper canon voilà il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire dessus
pour l'intégrer sur un produit fini mais
comme celle là c'est assez marrant là
par exemple vous auriez sur autrefois on
appuie sur l'arcade hop là vous avez
votre petit objectif qui s'ouvre en fait
le téléobjectif qui aura d'arrière et là
vous pouvez venir vous met dans l'image
zoomer ou dézoomer zoomer ou dézoomer
bon là on est sûr en 52 mm ça reste
malgré tout du fixe mais on pourra voir
une focale variable et l'idée en tout
cas assez rigolote côté innovation en
tout cas c'est super intéressant c'est
la caméra sous l'écran alors on l'a déjà
vu avec différents fabricants qui vous
ont présenté leurs solutions de la
caméra sous l'écran même si on voit que
c'est un peu les débuts et là hop au
bien montrer sa toute première
intégration d'une caméra cachée sous
l'écran ça permet effectivement d'aller
un peu plus haut les poinçons
disparaissent il ya plus dans coche je
vous montre leur intégration je la
trouve vraiment bien fait parce que
c'est bluffant et en regardant comme ça
on voit quasiment rien la caméra clank
et juste ici la voyait juste là on la
voit pas ça c'est marrant alors là vous
me direz en essayant tout coloré mais
lorsque je vais dans les paramètres sur
du blanc et ben on voit absolument rien
votre caméra elle est juste là alors
qu'on devine très très légèrement si on
regarde ça de très très près mais pour
nous en tout cas aujourd'hui c'est une
des meilleure intégration que j'ai pu
voir et lorsqu'on va sur la partie à
photo ob voyez vous comme mandela elle
est juste là des éléments devant vous
voyez la caméra y'a et lorsque et hop là
il vient comme ça elle disparaît donc
c'est vraiment bien fait c'est bluffant
alors c'est pas est la toute nouvelle
techno parce que on l'a déjà vu ailleurs
mais là je la trouve extrêmement bien
intégrés on doit être sur une caméra
l'ordre de 2 à 5 mégapixels mais comme
ces faits là c'est cool on pourrait
connu pour sa recharge rapide la superbe
boucle a pour l'instant on est à du 80
watts qui va être commercialisé qui
d'ailleurs commercialisé avec le finepix
cinq pros et là on nous annonce de la
recharge 150 watts alors je connais des
liens du sang droite qui est fait par
shiomi mail à 150 watts est aussi
intéressant pour recharger votre
smartphone à 50 % non seulement 5
minutes et vous le recharger à 100 % en
15 minutes ça veut dire que quelque part
la question de l'autonomie va on s'en
fout enfin un peu quand même que les
smartphones dur un petit peu mais vous
posez lui la question vous prenez vous
branchez cinq minutes et vous êtes
reparti pour un jour donc ça c'est
vachement cool et ça montre vraiment là
où va au pot alors c'est un peu moins
spectaculaire que la caméra qui bouge on
que la caméras planquées sous l'écran
néanmoins ça va dans le sens de
l'histoire et ça monte les innovations
que fait au pont donc tout ça a plutôt
intéressant à observer que ces chiens au
mieux d'un du sang à watts en cinq
combats qui ont duré ok 120 à 150 mais
bon petit à petit vous vous dites que
dans quelques années vous aller
recharger votre smartphone en quoi en
trois minutes vous le prenez vous le
branchez il est chargé et quand on aura
d'autres technologies de batteries et
bien on aura des batteries qui dureront
encore plus longtemps que se
rechargeront tout aussi vite donc voilà
c'est plutôt bien donc on se conçoit en
fait d'autonomie ça sera bientôt un non
sujet là je demande un truc de fou c'est
les eaux polaires glasses et le truc est
vraiment vraiment intéressant pourquoi
et bien vous le verrez pas c'est très
compliqué je sais pas ce que mais je
vais vous emmener danger vous expliquer
la regarde et je suis en face de moi
j'ai un menu donc j'ai des icônes comme
dans un smartphone est en fait mon
smartphone me sers comme un petit
pointeur laser donc je vois en fait ce
que je suis en train de pointer la chine
mon écran principal je tourne à gauche
c'est autre chose qui s'affiche j'ai mon
centre de notifications je reviens là
j'ai mes apps et je tourne à droite et
là j'ai mes infos j'ai la météo j'ai mon
horloge et là on fait voyez par exemple
alors j'ai différentes âmes j'en ai une
qui est super dingo je vous jure c'est
fou ça me permet de voir toutes les
constellations et toutes les étoiles
donc là je vais dessus et là je regarde
en l'air et la volière vous vous le
verrez pas mais je sais que vous
expliquer là j'ai une espèce de
constellation avec un lapin géant rio
labsus canis major et je vois le ciel
alors ils me font aimer membres du salon
là là je le vois gemini et ça ne dessine
en fait des figures avec les étoiles ce
truc est juste complètement dingue est
partout autour de moi je les en réalité
mixte c'est la réalité augmentée mais
sont légèrement enfoncé les lunettes ça
permet de voir permet de projeter et c
c'est démentiel alors j'ai des jeux
comme ça j'utilise tous directement
depuis depuis mon smartphone je suis
sorti j'ai mes albums photos alors par
exemple la voyais je vais dans mon album
photo ça va mais affiché toute une
galerie de photos cliquer sur n'importe
quelle photo là j'ai une photo en grand
et je peux swype est sur mon smartphone
hoc ça me fait changer de photo
directement avec mon pointeur laser le
truc est super dingo ce que j'aime bien
j'en ai déjà vu de la réalité augmentée
comme ceux de la réalité mixte parce que
je trouve vraiment intéressant ici est
bien c'est qu'on a vraiment de
l'applicatif on voit des choses et on
peut commencer à se projeter il faudrait
plutôt quelque chose d'un peu son mais
même laborieux il ya beaucoup de lumière
et ben je vois c'est cool dont je trouve
ça très marrant parce que en fait il
fini on va où avec ses idées de lunettes
à réalité augmentée réalité mixte et
bien c'est la suppression du smartphone
parce que même si les smartphones c'est
cool bassar est vachement embêtant
pourquoi parce que c'est contraignant
alors là ce qu'on voit au début c'est
que le début de l'histoire attention il
faut que j'aie un smartphone je suis
connecté avec des lunettes lourdes c'est
le tout début de l'histoire c'est pour
voir un truc fonctionnel donc c'est pas
dingue dingue mais quand on arrive à
quelque chose de très léger on se passe
de smartphones où on peut naviguer avec
des gestes ou en touchant et qu'on est
dans une vraie interface construit avec
beaucoup d'application il y aura des cas
d' usage de dengue et je vous dis ça à
terme dans cinq à dix ans et la fin du
smartphone on n'aura plus besoin d'avoir
un truc dans la main même si c'est cool
c'est un peu relou vous aurez toutes vos
caméras la forêt tout avec des gestes
vous aurait éventuellement une monde
connecté pour venir piloter des choses
mais c'est tout ça montre vraiment la
fin du smartphone tout le monde avec des
lunettes ou des lentilles on n'y est pas
tout de suite un ses horizons 5 10 ans
mais en tout cas les progrès sont là et
là voyage une interface qui est vraiment
fonctionnel et que je trouve très cool
je vais dans mon mes réglages brightness
volume vibrations enfin c'est ce qui est
très très cool j'adore ça et ça me plaît
beaucoup c'est parce que vous en pensez
vous dit clairement aux commentaires est
ce que vous vous sentiriez bien à l'idée
d'avoir des lunettes comme sa réalité
augmentée réalité mixte c'est un truc
qui pourrait vous tentez est-ce que vous
verriez dans la rue comme ça où tout le
monde serait en train de naviguer dans
ces parias de un peu flippant aussi
méchant ça tellement cool et là ce que
je vois je me suis roulé sur le salon je
peux pas rester des heures avec mais
j'adorerais y ait des petits jeux ça me
fait marrer quoi bon alors pour cool
j'adore truc est vachement intéressant
c'est les zergs l'es6 et les lunettes
connectés ne profère pas vraiment des
lunettes mais presque je vous explique
le truc regardez vous avez vos lunettes
deux courses assez juste des lunettes de
base et vous venez poser ce module
dessus qui vient sa tâche et qui vient
se connecter toi implore il éclipsait
c'est bien alors qu'est ce que j'ai la
réalité augmentée mais sur la partie
droite vient se rajouter sur mes
lunettes alors qu'est ce que je vois là
et bien je vois tout de suite leur je
vois la date je vois le niveau de
batterie et ensuite je viens ce rôle est
là en allant vers l'avant là je passe
sans mais évincé hier mais calendrier je
vois aujourd'hui tiens j'ai des
événements j'ai pas d'événement l'âge
avance j'ai ma santé les exercices donc
pas que j'ai fait mon activité je le
vois vraiment super position donc je
pense que c'est rigolo de voir mon
regard qui par un peu sur le côté
légèrement louche et peut-être l'âge et
la météo ici donc je suis géolocalisés
et ensuite là j'ai fait le tout alors
après il ya d'autres usages qui vont
arriver et qui sont intéressants ici
notamment de la traduction instantanée
pour l'instant ça ne fonctionne qu'en
anglais et en chinois mais on pourrait
imaginer n'importe quel donc si par
exemple eh bien moi vous me parlez en
italien si tu peux me parlera italien
dégrade ses mille et voilà d'un mois je
le verrai écrit en anglais ou en
français permet de converser très
facilement et de façon un peu naturel
vous avez également une fonction
prompteur qui est assez marrante lorsque
voulait faire une démonstration comme ça
eh bien vous avez votre texte qui
apparaît et vous pouvez soit faire un
slide comme ça pour venir à avancer
directement soit depuis des gestes avec
votre aux pauvres à java le truc est
plutôt rigolo c'est le début de
l'histoire voyez alors on connaît les
lui est en réalité mixte la réalité
augmentée de la réalité virtuelle mais
ça c'est encore un peu autre chose
c'est-à-dire vous avez vos lunettes avec
votre correction à vos yeux vous prenez
vous posez le module hop là voilà
lorsque vous avez besoin il est là et
lorsque vous n'avez plus besoin vous ne
prenez vous l'enlever et vous le ranger
donc il ya un côté un peu rigolo est ce
que je suis confortable avec ça ça ne
paraît pas mal après je suis à 32 g donc
je serais très très léger déséquilibre
mais franchement c'est léger donc c'est
une idée en tout cas de l'amour pour
aller avec de la réalité augmentée et
vous allez voir on s'arrête pas là et un
truc qui est marrant c'est qu'en plus
vous avez un petit haut parleur sur le
côté c est que vous pouvez entendre de
la musique mettre de la musique alors
sans le côté pourquoi pas pour avoir une
info rapidement après on va pas écouter
de la musique en ayant que d'un côté
comme ça avec un haut-parleur et l'autre
côté rien mais on peut néanmoins avoir
un petit retour je sais pas pourquoi pas
avoir faut voir les juges rageant c'est
vraiment le début vous voyez un peu ce
qui commence à se dessiner ce qui va
arriver chez au pot alors on est
vraiment des innovations attention c'est
vraiment le début que c'est parce qu'on
va avoir sur nos smartphones en 2022
clairement peut-être dans un an
peut-être dans deux ans en tout cas
c'est un travail d'innovation qui est
fait et c'est vachement intéressant
parce qu'on sait que au poète une marque
qui était dans le cinq en france qui
sont arrivés il ya quelques années
commence vraiment être connus
aujourd'hui sur le marché il aura fallu
un peu de temps mais en asie au pot
c'est énorme ils ont une force de frappe
qui est complètement dingue j'ai pu
parler avec un ingénieur ce qui est
super intéressant si vous voulez c'est
de voir la vision de voir où ils vont
aller des sites comprendre un peu ce qui
se dessine est ce qui va arriver on voit
une évolution qui va arriver sur la fin
du smartphone je pense à 10 15 ans même
s'ils nous disent pas c'est ce que j'ai
vraiment ce que je comprends et
j'imagine et c'est ce qui me paraît
tellement logique les mains libres qu'on
voit sur les smartphones c'est des
problématiques auxquelles on vient
répondre le fait d'avoir arrêté les
objectifs de bien meilleure qualité en
arrivant dans l'idée de l'optique on
peut venir zoomer avec une optique
l'idée des caméras sous l'écran se
libérer des contraintes c'est l'idée de
la technologie ses idées des smartphones
on se libère des contraintes convient
supprimer les problèmes de bruit sur les
images avec un téléobjectif avec un zoom
variable avec une vraie optique on vient
se libérer de la bulle de l'encoche sur
l'écran avec une caméra qui est planqué
de soi et de nouvelles technologies au
niveau des dalles on vient se libérer
les mains avec des casques à réalité
augmentée avec de la réalité mixte bref
tout ça vraiment passionnant et si ça
vous intéresse je vous ferai d'autres
vidéos on vient par les technologies on
vient par les innovations que ce soit
chez au pot ou d'autres à vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez en banque
commentaires qu'est ce que vous en
pensez quelle innovation est pour vous
la plus marquante la plus intéressante
fait de la recharge rapide que ce soit
les caméras bref vous marquez tout ça on
en parle bien évidemment dans les
commentaires et on va continuer à parler
de technologie et d'innovation parce que
là on est au mwc à barcelone il ya que
deux femmes la téléphonie donc on va en
bouffer et ça c'est bien allez je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
vite ciao
[Musique]